one by one turkey has begun sending
alleged ice members back where they came
from in Europe in Istanbul seven German
nationals among the men women and
children were put on a plane bound for
Berlin but another man has been sent to
the UK in a statement the Metropolitan
Police counterterrorism command
confirmed a 26 year old man was arrested
on suspicion of preparation of terrorist
acts on a section 5 of the Terrorism Act
2006 it went on to confirm the arrest is
Syria related tick tick tick tick this
America was also deported after spending
three days stuck in no-man's land after
Turkey tried to expel him to Greece
which refused to take him in it's not
clear of any of those thrown out by
Turkey today were captured during its
current offensive in Northeast Syria or
earlier but Turkey says it now has as
many as two and a half thousand people
in its jails thought to have been is
members there are many more in the hands
of turkeys enemies the Kurds in camps
and detention centers they hold
thousands the skinnies documented last
week their radicalized and many
extremely dangerous yet the world seems
incapable of deciding their fate
the UK's canceled the citizenship of
some hoping to dodge responsibility but
Turkey's president retropie Perot and
says that's unacceptable he and
president Trump this week increased
pressure on European nations to take
back their own they want to go back to
France and Germany and UK and all of
those other countries that are not
helping us I gave them the option would
you like to have him back and
intelligently they said no thank you but
that's not right and it's not fair as
European Nationals linked to Islamic
state start to return to the countries
they came from the question is where the
turkey intends to turn this trickle into
far more people and how their
governments will respond dominic Waghorn
Sky News